BARTON ZWIEBACH:
Finite square well.
So this brings us also
to a little common aside.
So far, we could
find every solution.
Now we're going to write the
equations for the finite square
well, and we're not going to
be able to find the solution.
But we're going to
understand the solution.
So you're going to
enjoy a little--
mathematicians usually say
it's the most important thing,
understanding the solution.
Finding it, it's no big deal.
But we're physicists as well.
So we sometimes have
to find the solutions.
Even if we don't
understand them very well,
it's nice to find them.
And then you're going to
use numerical methods,
and this is the part
of the course where
you're going to be using
numerical methods a lot.
Here is the finite
square well, and now we
draw it symmetrically.
Here it is.
Here is x.
We're drawing the
potential V of x.
It extends from a to minus a.
It's 0.
This is the 0 of the potential.
It's here.
And it goes down.
The potential is negative here.
Its value is minus
V0 with V0 positive.
And then a possible energy
for a bound state-- we're
going to look for bound states.
Bound states are normalizable
states, normalizable solutions
of the Schrodinger equation.
So we're going to look for them.
Look for bound states.
And they have
energy less than 0.
So something that has
energy less than 0 is bound.
You would have to give it some
energy to put it at 0 energy,
and the particle could escape.
The other thing
about the bound state
is that it will be some
probability to find it here.
Very little probability to find
it in the forbidden region.
And this energy, which is
negative, it's somewhere here.
We don't know what are
the possible energies,
but we will assume there's
some energy that is negative,
that is there.
And that's the energy
of the solution.
Let me write the equation again.
The equation is psi double prime
is minus 2m over h bar squared,
E minus V of x times psi.
This is the
Schrodinger equation.
You recognize it if you multiply
h squared here, 2m there.
And we've been solving
already two examples where
there was no potential, but
finally, there is a potential.
So this is the energy
of the particle.
The energy of the
particle can be
interpreted as the potential
energy plus the kinetic energy.
Think intuitively here.
If you have some
energy over here--
this is the potential energy.
Well, all this much
is kinetic energy.
On the other hand,
in this region,
the energy is smaller
than the potential energy.
So it has negative kinetic
energy, which is classically
not understandable.
And in quantum
mechanics, it just
will have some
probability of being here,
but that probability will
go down and eventually
go to 0 in such a way that the
wave function is normalizable.
So this is a very mysterious
thing that happens here,
that the wave function
will not be just over here,
but it will leak.
And it leaks because there's
a finite discontinuity.
If you take the barrier
to be infinitely high,
it would leak so little that
eventually it would not leak.
The wave function
would vanish there.
And it will be the
end of the story,
and you're back to the
infinite square well.
So the infinite square
well is a limit of this
as V0 goes to minus infinity.
OK, so a few numbers we
can put in this graph.
E, and this-- what is the
energy difference here?
It's E minus minus V0
, which is V0 plus E.
And many times
because E is negative,
we'll write it as V0
minus absolute value of E.
A negative number is equal
to minus its absolute value.
So how about this
whole constant here?
Well, my tongue slipped,
and I said this constant,
but it's V of x.
So what do you mean a constant?
Well, the potential
is piecewise constant.
So actually, we are not in
such difficult situation
because in this region, the
potential is a constant.
In this region, the
So this is the
constant here, and we
wish to understand
what it is and what
are the sines of this constant.
This constant, that
we call alpha--
see-- is going to be--
let's see what it is, the
different circumstances.
Suppose you are here.
The energy is bigger
than the potential.
So energy minus the
potential is positive,
and the constant is negative.
So alpha is negative
for x less than a.
If it's negative
and it's a constant,
you're going to have
trigonometric solutions
for x, absolute value
less than a, so trig.
On the other region,
alpha will be
positive for x greater
than a, and you will
have real exponentials of--
I'll just write exponentials.
So E to the minus 3x, E to
the 5x, things like that.
This is the difference
between trigonometric
and real exponential
solutions depend on the signs.
So we're going to have to
impose boundary conditions as
well because we're going
to solve the equation here
inside with one value of
alpha and then outside
with another value of alpha.
And then we're
going to match them.
So that's how this will go.
Now in this process,
somehow the energy
will be fixed to some
value, some allowed values.
There's a counting we could
do to understand that,
and we'll probably
do it next time.
At this moment,
we'll just proceed.
But we imagine there must
be a quantization because
in the limit as V0
goes to infinity
and the potential well
becomes infinitely deep,
you're back to an
infinite square well
that has quantized energies
that we calculated.
So that should be quantized,
and it should be no problem
OK, ready to do some work?
Let's-- Yes?
AUDIENCE: So when alpha is 0 and
you get polynomial solutions,
does that case not matter?
BARTON ZWIEBACH: When
alpha is 0-- well,
alpha is going to be never 0.
You see, either E is
less than the potential
or is better than the potential.
So you're not going
to get alpha equals 0.
You could say, do we have some
energy maybe here or here?
Well, you could have those
energies, in which case
you will see what happens.
It's not quite
polynomial solutions.
There's one property about
potentials that actually is
in the homework due this week,
which is that there cannot be
solutions of the Schrodinger
equation with less energy than
the minimum of the potential.
You have to have more
energy than the minimum
of the potential.
So alpha equal to 0 is not going
to show up in our analysis.
OK, so let's begin.
Moreover, we have
to use this result.
The potential is symmetric,
completely symmetric,
so there are going to be even
solutions and odd solutions.
So let's consider
the even solutions.
Solutions.
So those are solutions.
Psi of minus x is
equal to psi of x.
Now, you will see how
I solve this thing now,
and the lesson of all
of this is the relevance
of unit-free numbers.
Unit-free numbers are going
to be your best friends
in solving these equations.
So it will look like
I'm not solving anything
except making more and
more definitions, and all
of the sudden, the
solution will be there.
And it's a power of
notation as well.
This problem can be
very messy if you
don't have the right notation.
If you were solving it alone,
if we would stop the lecture now
and you would go home,
you would probably
find something very
messy for quite a bit.
And then maybe you clean
it up little by little,
and eventually,
something nice shows up.
So here's what
we're going to do.
We're solving for x in between
a and minus a, even solutions.
So what does the equation
look like? d second psi d
x squared is minus 2m over
h squared E minus V of x--
in that region, the
potential is minus V0.
So this is minus 2m
over h squared, V0
plus E, which I write as minus
absolute value of E, psi.
And I forgot a psi here.
OK.
V0 is positive.
Minus V0 is going down, and V0
minus the absolute value of E
is positive.
So this whole quantity
over here is positive.
And here it comes,
first definition.
I will define k squared
to be that quantity--
2m over h squared V0
minus absolute value of E.
And that's greater
than 0 in this region,
as we're trying to solve, and
I'll call this equation one.
And the differential
equation has become psi
double prime is minus k psi.
So the solutions are simple.
It's trigonometrics, as we
said, and the only solution-- k
squared, I'm sorry.
k squared-- and
the only solution
that is possible, because
it's a symmetric thing,
is cosine of kx.
So psi of x is going
to be cosine of kx,
and that will hold
from a to minus a.
End of story, actually, for
that part of the potential.
You could ask-- one second.
You could say, you're going
to normalize these things,
aren't you?
Well, the fact that I
won't normalize them,
it's just a lot of work,
and it's a little messy.
But that's no problem.
You see, you're finding
energy eigenstates,
and by definition,
solving the differential
equation is not going to
give you a normalization.
So this is a good solution
of the differential equation,
and let's leave it at that.
This we'll call solution two.
How about the region
x greater than a?
Well, what does the
differential equation look like?
Well, it looks like psi double
prime is equal to minus 2,
m over h squared, E psi
because the potential is 0.
V0 outside.
x equals a.
And here again, you want
to look at the equation
and know the sign.
So maybe better to put
the absolute value here.
So this is 2m absolute value
of E over h squared psi.
And one more definition--
kappa squared is going
to be 2mE over h squared.
That's equation number three.
The equation has become
psi double prime equals
kappa squared psi, and
the solutions for that
are exponentials.
Solutions are psi-- goes like
E to the plus minus kappa x.
You see the solution we're
constructing is symmetric.
It's even.
So let's worry just
about one side.
If one side works, the other
side will work as well.
So I will just write
that for psi of x
is equal to the minus kappa x.
That's a solution
for x greater than a.
If I just did that, I
would be making a mistake.
And the reason is
that yes, I don't
care about the normalization
of the wave function,
but by not putting
a number here,
I'm selecting some
particular normalization.
And The wave function must
be continuous and satisfy
all these nice things.
So yes, here I can maybe
not put a constant,
but here, already, I
must put a constant.
It may be needed to match
the boundary conditions.
I cannot ignore it here.
So I must put the constant
a that I don't know,
and that's going to be
equation number four.
Now, look at your definitions.
k squared for a
trigonometric, kappa--
many people use kappa for things
that go with exponentials.
But look, k squared
and kappa squared
satisfy a very nice relation.
If you add them up--
k squared plus kappa squared--
the energy part cancels,
and you get 2mV0, which
is positive, over h squared.
Well, that's not so bad, but we
want to keep defining things.
How can I make this really nice?
If it didn't have units,
it would be much nicer.
This is full of units.
k times a length has no units,
and kappa times a length
has no unit.
So multiply by a
squared, and you have k
squared a squared
plus kappa squared
a squared is equal to 2mV0
a squared over h squared.
Now, say, well yes,
this looks nice.
So let's make the
new definitions.
So don't lose track
of what we are doing.
We need to find the energy.
That's basically what we want.
What are the possible energies?
And we already included
two constants--
k and kappa- and they have
these properties here.
So let me define
psi to be kappa a,
and it will be defined
to be positive.
Kappa is defined to
be positive, and k
is defined to be positive.
eta, you will define it to
be ka. a It's unit-free.
No units.
And from that equation,
now we have eta
squared plus psi squared is
equal to the right-hand side,
which I will call z0 squared.
So z0 squared-- that's
another definition--
is 2mV0 a squared
over h squared.
This is the list of
your definitions.
OK.
What did we do?
We traded kappa and k
that control the behavior
of the wave function--
k inside the well,
kappa outside the well--
we traded them for eta
and psi, unit-free.
And a new constant came up, z0.
What is z0?
Well, z0 is a very
interesting constant.
It's a number that
you can construct out
of the parameters
of your potential.
It involves V0 and the width.
If V0 is very
large, z0 is large.
If the width is
very big, z0 is big.
If the potential is shallow
or very narrow, z0 is small.
But the most important
thing about z0
is that it will give you
the number of bound states.
If z0 is very big, it's
a very deep potential,
we'll have lots of bound states.
If z0 is very shallow, there
will be one bound state,
no more.
You will see it today.
But z0 controls the
number of bound states.
And this is its role, and
it will be very important--
these dimensionless
quantities and number.
If somebody says, I have a
potential with z0 equals 5,
you can tell immediately
three bound states
or some number of bound states.
That's the nice thing about z0.
And this is a very
nice-looking equation,
this equation of a circle
in the eta-xi plane.